[Risas]
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tú
amor
[Música]
la casa con tu ropa al boyacá chicó
consumo a tu ruta el collar talle tocuyo
ahorro para la casa y con la colocamos
causa y cura a tu lo calcula el cachito
consumo a tu ruta y boyacá chicó consumo
[Música]
el volcán serias para recortar sobre
carburantes para recortar sobre tantas
capas de altar tuxpan tantas tapas de
cartón
[Música]
del mundo ella es más importante sobre
tan muy manchegas más me corta el checho
le falta yuca para tartar tu culpa del
cambio capa larga tu cuerpo
[Música]
rojo
[Risas]
[Aplausos]
qué les pareció maravillosa la voz
humana nuestra voz y más aún cuando
cantamos cuando lo hacemos en colectivo
como acaban de escuchar lo cambiamos no
solamente nuestro entorno sino
posiblemente el mundo bueno que les
puedo contar cuando yo estaba dirigiendo
el coro de no videntes del ecuador
imagínense el reto que me propusieron a
mí los no videntes del ecuador yo decía
cómo voy a hacer esto si no me pueden
ver como dirijo si no me pueden ver la
marcación entonces resulta que solamente
el canto la respiración humana no
sintonizó de una manera increíble
estos chicos lograron cantar a cuatro
voces independientes polifónicas cada
una de ellas solamente con la
respiración y el pulso de lo que
significa el cantar el latir el
sincronizarnos como sociedad como seres
humanos maravilloso de verdad que ese
reto fue una de las cosas más grandes
que me ha pasado otra de las cosas que
les puedo contar así interesantes fue
que estaba yo en un ensayo y golpean la
puerta del lugar de ensayo y me dicen
muy bueno
disculpe aquí es donde se hacen bordados
para el paréntesis estaba buscando un
lugar la señora donde se podían hacer
bordados de no ser tejidos y le digo no
señor aquí no abordamos tejidos pero
abordamos voces y la señora se fue así
como un poco diciendo bueno muchas
gracias y se retiró dos años después
consigue mi correo consigue mi contacto
y me escribe y me dice bueno usted tenía
la razón ahora yo vivo en australia
pertenezco a un coro y sabe que
abordamos las voces y cantamos todos en
paz para mí fue una noticia increíble
porque si yo creo mucho en esto del
canto y creo que lo estoy demostrando
con estas maravillas algo más que les
puedo contar un amigo mío viene después
de algún tiempo de no haber cantado
después de algún tiempo de no no haber
hecho música con con miel personalmente
ni con otras personas viene y me dice
estoy muy enfermo estoy un poco
complicado de salud los médicos no
atinan conmigo incluso estaba
tartamudeando se los digo con honestidad
estaba no podía pronunciar bien las
palabras entonces le dijo bueno
yo te recibo en el coro y vamos a ver
hasta donde avanzamos ustedes no me van
a creer esto pero después de un año de
trabajar con nosotros en el coro primero
que dejó de tener problemas en el habla
de verdad ya no tiene problemas en el
habla su salud se mejoró ciento por
ciento salió adelante con su salud y hoy
ha vuelto a cantar imagínense ha vuelto
a cantar como solista retomo los pasos
que él tenía de ser solista entonces yo
ya no me estoy inventando nada de que no
sea comprobable todo lo contrario les
puedo decir con fe que el canto nos
ayuda que el canto nos da liviana que el
canto realmente nos pertenece a todos
porque nacemos con el canto porque
nacemos absolutamente con nuestra voz
lista para compartir con los demás y
bueno esas han sido un poco anécdotas
que a mí me encanta contarlas porque en
ese sentido creo que compartir nuestro
canto es uno de los retos más
importantes
yo personalmente pienso que de alguna
manera tenemos que poner puntos de apoyo
tenemos que poner puntos
como para que el canto nos llegue a todo
el mundo qué les parece si es que en las
escuelas los chicos las chicas las niñas
pudiesen cantar desde niños y así en
conjunto que les parece que nuestras
universidades colegios instituciones
públicas privadas tuviesen sus oros
tuviesen sus talleres de canto sus
talleres de arte sería fantástico porque
no estaríamos buscando otro tipo de
argumentos para sentirnos bien si
considero personalmente que tal vez una
de las cosas que nos faltan nosotros
mejorar es que respetemos el canto que
nos respetemos a nosotros como personas
que procuramos el canto para los demás
de una manera como que fuese una
profesión que de hecho la es más
tradicional en nuestro país y en el
mundo a qué me refiero que esté a la par
de otras profesiones convencionales de
otras profesiones que de alguna manera
tienen mucho más auge porque si no es
bien gracioso yo hasta ahora recuerdo no
me miren ya tengo unos cuantos años ya
pasaditos y todavía hay personas que me
hacen bueno en qué trabajas y yo les
digo yo soy músico soy cantante y meses
no podían ser yo en qué trabajas
entonces les digo no en serio soy
cantante y soy profesor de canto
diciendo pero ya qué te dedicas ya
seriamente porque has de ser algo
formalmente en la vida entonces yo y
siempre discuto peleo me pongo un poco
en este asunto de explicar lo que es el
canto y lo que es la música pero evaluó
que nuestra sociedad si tuviera ese
respeto si tuviese esta posibilidad de
mirar al arte como realmente un camino
pues creo que estaríamos dando pasos más
agigantados y eso provocaría que eso no
se nuestra comunidad' pidiese solicita
hace un poco más de arte para poder
vivir creo que nosotros mismo podemos
pedir al estado ecuatoriano no sé a todo
el mundo que nos escuchen y que
necesitamos más arte para cambiar en
nuestros barrios de nuestra casa en
nuestro entorno pero bueno son ideas que
yo tengo a veces como digo soñar no
cuesta nada pero la lucha que hemos
hecho en este tiempo es algo que empieza
a dar frutos por lo menos en pequeñas
células en las que trabajamos espero
estén de acuerdo conmigo nunca más
vuelvan a decir a mí que sólo cantan en
la ducha y eso ustedes ya saben que no
aquí yo les estoy mirando a todos
están aquí rodeándome en el set y
algunos me mueven la cabeza y me dicen
no nosotros cantamos solo en la ducha o
cantamos solamente así cuando estamos a
solas pues yo les voy a comprobar que
eso no es cierto les voy a comprobar
este instante de que todo el mundo
cantamos y cantamos siempre que queremos
y estamos en paz con nosotros mismos me
voy a atrever a cantar una canción de la
tradición mexicana pero que es una
canción que estoy seguro todo el mundo
la conoce estoy más que seguro que la
conoce y cuando yo les diga así ustedes
de seguro van a cantar conmigo se lo
demuestro para que vean que no solamente
cantamos en la ducha
si verán
bien en esto
yo sé bien que estoy afuera pero el día
en que yo me muera sé que tendrás que
llorar
eso vino dirás que no me quisiste pero
vas a estar muy triste y así te vas a
quedar
verdad con dinero y sin dinero hago
siempre lo que quiero
y mi palabra es la ley
y esto se lo saben ustedes no tengo
trono ni reina ni nadie que me comprenda
pero sigo siendo
eso
[Aplausos]
como que no cantan ustedes llevan a
decir a mí que no cantan pues yo no les
creo todos cantamos así que nos falta
para cantar con más espacio bueno en
esta época loca de la de la pandemia en
esta época tenemos que conversar con
nuestra gente del condominio tenemos que
conversar con nuestra gente del barrio
decirle que estamos en clases de canto
decirle que por favor nos perdonen en la
horita de clase de canto la horita del
ensayo del coro y todo el asunto para
que no haya molestias pero más allá de
eso porque no les invitamos venga a
vecino cante conmigo pero yo sé cantar
un poquito toco la guitarra venga
súmese yo yo le pido cante mire le
enseño una canción mire el dúo que
hacemos que si yo si hijos vengan canten
con nosotros abuelos tíos padres amigos
cantemos hagamos de nuestra vocación
humana el proyecto más grande en la
naturalidad de lo que significa
mostrarnos con lo que somos con lo que
tenemos y nuestra voz humana es nuestra
identidad
pienso yo que si reclamamos un poquito
en nuestro barrio en nuestro espacio en
nuestro estado más arte va a funcionar
pienso yo que si le decimos a nuestro
vecino de aquel lado que estamos iguales
que el vecino puede ser el médico muy
importante el abogado el ingeniero pues
uno puede ser el médico
el médico de almas con la música con el
canto también muy importante también muy
grande entonces yo sí pienso que ahí
vamos a corregir un poquito este espacio
que hace que nosotros no cantemos bueno
comprarse una ducha nueva también es un
motivo de celebración para aquellos que
dicen cantamos en la ducha imagina ese
pero para que no gasten tanto comprando
se ducha cada semana preferible que lo
canten ya no solamente en la ducha
preferible que cantemos en todos los
espacios que nos competen que los niños
canten que desde pequeñitos ellos logren
de mostrarnos su naturaleza su alegría a
través del canto miren que los niños
antes de aprender a escribir a leer
cantan miren ustedes y nosotros llegamos
a la escuela y al colegio y él decimos
no cante está un poco loco esta verdad
pero bueno siguen siendo mis ideas
siguen siendo estos sueños que quiero
compartirles con ustedes creo que les he
comprobado que tienen hermosas voces no
solamente que cantan creo que ustedes
saben y entienden que sus voces es lo
más preciado que tenemos no solamente
para hablar y comunicarnos sino para
vibrar juntos cuando cantamos así que
les dejo esto piénsenlo con el canto tal
vez no cambiamos todo el mundo pero si
lo hacemos mejor así que bueno a cantar
todos les parece
[Aplausos]